l'heure du panel a sonné avec un panel
un peu particulier aujourd'hui étant
donné l'actualité du jour je salue
d'entrée de jeu sébastien beauvais et
daniel renaud journaliste à la presse
bonjour à vous messieurs alors bien
évidemment bonsoir plutôt effectivement
de 7 à 36 ont prédit un bon soir à l'ats
daniel évidemment vous êtes là titre de
spécialiste des affaires criminelles à
montréal
vous avez été passés à travers vous
qu'on a appris un peu ce qui s'en venait
en cours de journée
et là je pense qu'on doit quand même
prendre le temps d'établir certaines
choses notamment sur le plan
chronologique on va se fier à ce que
aujourd'hui monsieur prudhomme a dit et
affirmé aux micros de tout un matin en
entrevue avec patrick masbourian voici
comment ça se décline le 23 octobre 2017
il y eut cet appel à malam à mettre à
nick murphy directrice du dpcp voyez qu
ici qu'en mars 2019
monsieur prudhomme selon lui encore une
fois je le rappelle est convoqué au
secrétariat aux emplois supérieurs on
lui apprend qu'il est suspendue en
raison d'allégations et d'entravé de but
d'entraver d'abus de confiance
on se transporte en mars 2020 su
prud'hommes est convoqué encore une fois
il apprend à ce moment là dit il que la
plainte qui a mené à sa suspension est
liée à son appel à m murphy
il ya une enquête du bio y qui ne mène à
aucune accusation criminelle mais il ya
toutefois un comité d'experts qui se
penche sur une faute déontologique a
légué en mai 2020 une suprise hommes
affirment qu'il est invité à rencontrer
le comité d'experts qui ne lui pose
aucune question dit-il avant pendant et
après cet entretien l'été 2020 survient
ses avocats discutent avec le
gouvernement et monsieur prudhomme
affirme qu'on lui a fait miroiter le
processus de disciplinaire à son endroit
sûr interrompu s'il annoncé sa retraite
est finalement hier monsieur prudhomme à
te prends dit-il en soirée que madame
petit bout s'apprête à l'ancien
troisième processus pour déterminer s'il
a bel et bien commis une faute grave
d'ordre déontologique
waouh daniel dans tout ça il ya beaucoup
d'ombré au tableau notamment sur la
nature des reproches et des fautes qui
lui sont imputées oui bah écoutez il ya
une grande ombre
de 16 mois parce que dans la chronologie
il manque quand même un gros morceau
entre le fameux appel litigieux entre
martin prud'homme et annick morphée et
le jour où années que ma fille décide de
porter plainte contre martin prud'homme
c'est à dire le 6 mars 2010 neuf
journées où il est relevé de ses
fonctions
il s'écoule 16 mois et évidemment on
peut se poser la question pourquoi avoir
attendu 16 mois avant de décider de
déposer la plainte
on va revenir en arrière 23 octobre 2017
ces deux jours avant l'arrestation de
guy ouellette
pourquoi parce que guy ouellette était
soupçonné par l'upac d'avoir coulé des
documents sensibles d'une enquête
majeure de l'upac sur le financement du
parti libéral du québec le projet manche
jurés et tutorat j'entendais isabel
richer qui se posaient la question parce
que la plaie avec raison d'ailleurs
parce que la plaie danic main fait
c'était pour entraver abus de confiance
et ça correspond pas du tout à l'appel
que martin prud'homme prétend avoir vu
avec m me refais aucune autre plainte
mais mais il ya un contexte alexis il y
aurait 23 octobre 2007 deux jours avant
l'arrestation de guy ouellette un
contexte de possibilité d'autoriser des
mandats dans la quête sur guy ouellette
peut-être même des modes des courtes
est ce que ces mandats à réviser martin
prud'homme est ce que martin prud'homme
le 23 octobre lorsqu'il appelle avec ma
fille celle-ci croit qu' il veut
entraver le travail des policiers dans
leur cas est sûr guy ouellette
alors que lui l'appelle simplement parce
que il veut que cesse du salissage à son
endroit qui semble-t-il est fait par des
procureurs donc dont m
marie est la patronne il ya tout ça là
toute cette période là c'est seize mois
là aussi pourquoi avoir entendu 16 mois
ils sont extrêmement nébuleux j'espère
qu'un jour on jours on aura les réponses
et peut-être éventuellement dans les
prochains jours il ya un autre aspect
aussi qui est important et je vais
laisser la parole à ses basques et par
la suite je veux pas prendre tout son
temps
mais l'autre aspect c'est que martin
prud'homme a entre les mains le fameux
rapport accablant rapport de 27 pages
sur 27 pages il ya dix pages manquantes
que contiennent ces dix pages manquantes
et est-ce que c'est sur un rapport dans
lequel il manque 10 pages que la
ministre guilbeault a pris la décision
ce matin de décidé de pousser encore
plus loin le processus de destitution de
martin prud'homme
ça aussi il va falloir qu'on sache un
moment donné et madame guilbeault était
très évasive sébastien oui évasive pas
ce qu'il dit je veux protéger les droits
de monsieur prudhomme j'ai pas le droit
de rendre public le rapport puis elle a
été habile aussi d'une certaine façon en
renvoyant le fardeau de rendre public ce
rapport sur les épaules de monsieur
prudhomme
mais quel rapport il rend un public me
suis pris dans un mirror le public celui
qu'il a en même temps qu'elle y manque
des pages où le véritable rapport plus
étoffé bon c'est tout les des questions
nombre c'est passionnant d'entendre
daniel parce que oui il ya un conte très
très bien l'histoire au point de vue
politique
peut-être que la bonne nouvelle c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour essayer de jeter
un peu de lumière sur ces zones comme
c'est que la commission la fonction
publique c'est un tribunal quasi
judiciaire donc il a le pouvoir tu ma
compréhension est bonne elle à la
commission le pouvoir de demander à ce
que des gens viennent témoigner devant
la commission et devant ce tribunal
quasi judiciaire et donc est ce que à ce
moment là à nick murphy va être convoqué
à ce que geneviève guilbault être
convoqué probablement martin prud'homme
à être convoqués aussi est ce qu'à ce
moment là on pourrait mettre un peu de
lumière sur ces zones d'ombré peut-être
que le processus va nous permettre de
faire ça au cours des prochains mois est
lui-même un dit qu'il avait souhaité que
certains témoins qui vous le voulez
faire témoigner sont entendus et ça n'a
pas été le cas selon lui
daniel on se pose la question quel est
le calcul de monsieur prudhomme dans
tout celui qui quitte l aude loin des
courts aujourd'hui avant que la ministre
se prononce les écouter c'est ça peut
être un excellent calcul visiblement bon
il savait que la ministre que tu as pour
faire une annonce aujourd'hui et il a
décidé de devancer le coup de sortir
publiquement lui même est de passer à
l'attaqué juillet par les tard hier soir
alexis et sébastien et oui son entourage
me dit qu'il a qu'il a subi un choc qui
le prend très durement
mais si vous l'avez également entendu ce
matin en entrevue à paul arcand on est
loin d'un homme mais qui est abattu on
est face à un homme qui au contraire a
décidé de contre attaquer et lorsque je
vous ai raconté le contexte possible du
fameux appel du 23 octobre 2010 à tout à
l'heure
est ce que tout ça et j'espère que non
mais est ce que tout ça est une histoire
de malentendus entre martin prud'homme
et m annick main fait ceci c'est le cas
c'est certain que monsieur prudhomme à
qui j'ai posé la question hier allez
vous poursuivre le gouvernement
c'est certain que il va passer à
l'attaqué
encore plus que ce qu'il a pu faire
aujourd'hui mais mais pas saisie de
secondaire ou si c'est vraiment
seulement l'appel de martin prud'homme à
nick murphy
il a fallu qu'il utilise des mots
inimaginable pour parler avec mal à me
fait au point où trois experts nommés
par le gouvernement vient à la
conclusion que le processus de
destitution
pas de suspension pas de note au dossier
pas de dire votre chez vous quelques
semaines tu reviendras mais de
destitution soit entrepris alors
qu'est-ce qui a eu dans cette
conversation si c'est en effet cette
conversation téléphonique
quels ont été les mots utilisés quel
était le temps utilisé
comment madame leur fils a été arrêté
tout ça pour l'instant c'est un mystère
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que si tu as
été jugé assez grave pour enclencher le
processus de destitution d'un directeur
général de la sûreté du québec c'est
pareil elle s'est mariée mais c'en est
approuvée aux deux tiers par l'assemblée
les élus de l'assemblée nationale
c'est pas une course acquise sébastien
alors c'est peut-être ça aussi le calcul
qui va au final ça aura pas lieu cette
destitution mais comment imaginer son
métier dans les circonstances à son
poste
la clé c'est la commission de la
fonction publique c'est la commission
d'information publique recommande la
destitution ce soit au bureau du premier
ministre qui lui présente une motion à
l'assemblée nationale recommandant la
destitution
si la commission de la fonction publique
éclaircies tous ceux qui en vient à la
conclusion que c est un malheureux
malentendu puis que ya pas de fondement
à destituer monsieur prudhomme
attention là il aura certainement un
arsenal avec lui pour poursuivre le
gouvernement dans cette affaire là mais
la clé finalement tout cas la cléac'h à
court moyen terme
c'est la commission de la fonction
publique très bien alors on attendra
cette prochaine étape a qu'un bain on ne
sait pas comme d'isabelle il n'y a pas
de d'échéancier à respecter
nécessairement daniel renaud merci
beaucoup ont souhaité une soirée merci
pour cette participation panel on va
souhaiter la bienvenue maintenant et
comme par magie l'appareil de blaye
m'aurait bonjour madeleine bonsoir alors
parlons maintenant de racisme est
systémique et puisqu'aujourd'hui
madeleine ottawa convoqué pas mal de
monde en conférence zoom 400 personnes
j'espère qu'ils aient la majorité
s'étaient mis sur mu ou de peindre à
discussion mais même pas ce qu'est
vraiment l'heure est grave le
gouvernement trudeau considère qu'il ya
racisme systémique dans le réseau de la
santé notamment
parlons du message envoyé deux par
ottawa aujourd'hui le message envoyé par
ottawa c'était une rencontre pour
écouter ottawa avait l'impression
d'avoir parlé que des policiers avaient
eu la chance de s'exprimer
il tenait à entendre les différents
intervenants dans le système de santé
mais c'est une première rencontre le
ministre des affaires ou des services
aux autochtones mark miller disait il
faut commencer par commencé donc c'est
on est au tout début de ce processus là
il va y avoir une autre rencontre en
janvier mais il va falloir un moment
donné qui est de l'action concrète parce
que on a beaucoup débattu de termes
d'expression de racisme système et qui
avait d'ailleurs à la rencontre le
ministre québécois des affaires aux
autres aux autochtones
le nouveau ministre eliane la trainière
et ça faisait une dynamique un peu
particulière parce que la rencontre
c'était pour essayer d'éliminer le
racisme systémique au sein des systèmes
de santé alors que monsieur lafreniere
fait partie d'un gouvernement qui ne
reconnaît pas le terme racisme
systémique
en bout de la rencontre on a su que
selon monsieur miller que monsieur la
fresnière s'était engagé à avoir des
mesures concrètes à proposer de l'action
donc monsieur mais leurs 100 ans avec
lui là dessus et monsieur lafrenière a
dit que nous savons que la tragédie
survenue à joliette n'est pas un
événement isolé donc on sent quand même
que c'est pas un cas unique
la mort de johnny c'est chaque one qui a
eu d'autres événements empreints de
racisme donc ça c'est la rencontre il y
aura des suites à tout ça il faudra voir
si on réussit à maintenir cet élan le la
mort de madame et chaque one a vraiment
attristé le québec il ya eu une vague
d'indignation on va voir si dans
quelques mois on n'est pas encore
capable d'agir rapidement dans ce
dossier avant de poursuivre écoutons
monsieur trudeau justement qui s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui en marge de cette
rencontre tenue par marie
on a beaucoup fait en termes de
gouvernement fédéral mais il ya plus qu
on doit faire en tant que canadiens mais
ceci implique tous les différents ordres
de gouvernement
nous devons tous faire le travail
difficile d'améliorer un pays de contrer
le racisme systémique
ouais contre le racisme systémique dans
le réseau de la santé la santé c'est une
compétence provinciale
la question autochtone fédéral pas
souvent de tout son poids dans ce
dossier il est là un peu le noeud du
problème sébastien oui parce que il ya
des gens qui vous dirait que le
gouvernement fédéral
oui veut peut-être monsieur trudeau
peut-être parler de racisme systémique
mais devrait peut-être s'occuper de
problèmes plus fondamentaux d'avec les
communautés et les nations autochtones
l'accès à de l'eau courant
l'accès à du logement digne de ce nom
aussi des choses qui sont
essentiellement de juridiction fédérale
alors ici à québec on se dit bon c'est
bien beau de vouloir discuter de racisme
système et que c'est un enjeu important
qu'il faut régler c'est à dire par le
racisme systémique mais le racisme parce
que la version ici à québec
il n'arrête un racisme mais il ya aussi
des enjeux plus fondamentaux des enjeux
fondamentaux comme l'accès à des décades
ya une qualité de vie
de base alors on est prêt à faire la
discussion sur le racisme à changer les
choses dans la façon dont certains
employés de l'état se comporte vis à vis
des communautés autochtones mais on
n'est pas prêt encore connaître ni les
racismes systémique ni la discrimination
systémique avait été reconnue par la
commission revient en passant mais on
veut trouver des solutions pour montrer
le racisme de certains québécois à
l'égard des autochtones et là dessus
sont là est la question des champs de
compétence alexis ce qui est particulier
c'est que le gouvernement fédéral veut
proposer une loi c'est dans la lettre de
mandat du ministre mais leur veut
proposer une loi
coécrite avec les peuples autochtones
sur la santé des autochtones
donc là le gouvernement québécois
pourrait y voir encore une fois un
empiètement dans les champs de
compétence des provinces
donc on même s'il ya de la bonne volonté
là autour de la table pour essayer
d'améliorer le système pour essayer de
retirer le racisme de sexisme le racisme
ou les événements raciste il y a quand
même cette dynamique fédérale
provinciale où les champs de compétence
ça reste un enjeu
ça reste un prêt que préoccupations
québec - oui comme sébastien un peu plus
tôt sur nos ondes il doit il va avoir de
plus en plus de friture sur la ligne
on passe on parle du dossier autochtone
sébastien mais aussi les normes
fédérales en soins de santé avec toute
la question de la combine oui et ça
c'est une fin de non-recevoir de
françois legault sa vie françois legault
il est le président du conseil de la
fédération
il a une espèce de frais au front commun
des promesses vis-à-vis du fédéral pour
demander plus de transferts en santé
essentiellement en dix ans on a des
besoins dans les provinces vous avez
l'argent transféré nous de l'argent puis
on va gérer comme bon nous sommes dans
nos provinces parce que c'est nous qui
donnons les soins de santé alors quand
le gouvernement fédéral avait rives avec
des normes nationales pour les ch et
céder les provinces réagissent aux jo
mais on a déjà d'énormes nous on
comprend on essaie déjà de prendre soin
de nos aînés
le problème c'est un problème de
ressources donnez-nous l'argent pour
avoir les ressources à illies à cet
empiètement la région de compétences en
même temps on comprend un peu ce que
monsieur trudeau a essayé de faire il
essaie de se positionner pour un peu
comme un bon père de famille puis dire
qu'il veut prendre soin des canadiens
certains diront qu'ils parlent plus aux
canadiens que au premier ministre et que
sept
cette prise de position du premier
ministre contre sa volonté et pas
nécessairement si importante que ça à
partir du moment où il fait passer le
message qu'il veut s'occuper des
canadiennes dans les chu s'il n'ya pas
madeleine un parfum de électorale dans
tout ça
le parfum électoral c'est pas de se
batailler avec québec parce que ça ça
peut être quand même un peu dangereux au
gouvernement on est minoritaire
rappelez-vous les libéraux sont
minoritaires et ils ont l'impression que
la majorité où certains du moins on a
l'impression que la majorité passe par
le québec donc se batailler avec québec
c'est quand même un jeu dangereux quand
la crise est encore si populaire quand
la question des champs de compétence
s'est porté par le bloc québécois par le
par le parti conservateur aussi dans une
certaine mesure
ottawa donc ça c'est 1 2 c'est un jeu
dangereux comme dirait françois legault
de jouer sur le le dossier des champs de
compétence mais en même temps le
gouvernement fait sûrement de paris qui
le plus à gagner à montrer aux canadiens
qu'ils se soucient des aînés parce qu'il
ya eu cette crise quand même lors de la
première vague et le gouvernement essaie
de dire regardez nous on est là pour
essayer d'améliorer le système sait donc
ce qui est plus important que les champs
de compétences donc le pari il est là
qui va gagner son erreur lors des
élections verra bien on s'aventure
rapport à la prédiction dans la
futurologie mais c'est ça la politique
la prise de risque merci beaucoup
sébastien mauvais madeleine blé morin je
vous souhaite un bon week-end reposez
vous bien revenez nous en forme